ding ding he's the expert there he
showed his understanding his superior
experience and
maybe prague needs to mix it up maybe
serve with a different hand maybe play a
king's pawn opening play the english
like ding did in the last game mix
things up that's the way often to beat
your opponents don't keep battering your
head against the same wall
and uh yeah we're waiting anxiously yeah
his first move attention before game
three starts they are both ready i have
to say ding now he looks fresher he
looks uh ready to fight and here we go
yep here we go queen spawn opening he's
surprised by this one it looks like he's
repeating the same thing ah okay this
knight move slightly different so
slightly different variation but it is
the queen's gambit declined
ding here there's a variety of moves
they call this the main position or at
least alexander gristrok does because
black has six or seven very
sensible moves okay he goes for
uh just a kind of nice solid pawn
position
oh this one is until this last move it
was about to lead into one of the most
complex most aggressive openings out
there in chess
this is the semi-slav now if you look at
black structure there's kind of a
triangle formation the black pawns
ivanka what do you think of this choice
by both players actually yeah it's uh
very very solid and i think it's the
right way to go because uh the
the other line which would be wild wild
wild as if black gets greedy and
captures material don't touch that
unless you know what you're doing and we
have we have an opening on the board
when the queen comes out it's actually
called the cambridge springs oh uh it
was played
in america this time this uh opening
yeah i'm not sure exactly when but it's
quite an old opening yeah it is a very
old opening and history definitely
should we show the famous trap in the
cambridge springs oh there's a couple of
traps here um which one do you want to
show your anchor if the white bishop
develops yeah
for example this bishop if it comes out
um there are a few problems uh firstly
there's a pin and also the black queen
does stare down along this along this
line at one of the white bishops so for
example here black can just capture a
pawn distract away the white bishop and
jumping in with the knight now wins a
material this bishop is actually
attacked not just by the knight but also
by the queen from far away and uh now
once the bishop moves always protected
then the black knight can actually
capture and we would see a situation
like this where black has just won a
pawn for free and you give a check and
it looks like you're about to win the
bishop the white knight can jump back
and block but this is very good for
black this is one of the main tricks uh
one of the main traps but of course
prague he's too good to fall into a trap
on just move eight instead he trades a
set of pawns and brings his queen one
square forward just defending this
knight and loads of pressure on this
knight now suddenly this is uh a mega
pin
uh using the black bishop using the
black queen staring down along this
diagonal it's all about trying to break
through on this piece so white has to
rush and defend it this white rook now
sufficiently defending this knight
and uh okay kicking away this bishop we
will likely see at some point maybe
prague get aggress ding sorry get
aggressive and start throwing pawns down
the board uh if ding wants to play safe
maybe he'll just castle away to safety
but i don't think that's on his mind
right now you don't choose this
variation just to timidly castle your
king and allow your opponent's pieces
out it's all about whether white's king
can rush away to safety if he can and
prague is doing great but if dean can
whip up an attack before that then yeah
who knows what will happen it could be a
very very interesting game
cool i don't think we've seen this
opening on the tour actually the
cambridge springs at all
no i i don't recall seeing it i myself
either um but it's a very very popular
uh opening at all levels and it's it's
kind of become very trendy now because
it was dismissed for a long time has
been oh
you hear this word so many times when it
comes to openings but it's just a
stylistic thing okay it's boring it's
boring getting fun why are you playing
like this is old manchester old people
play like this why are you trying to
kill the risk but uh you know
now with computers discovering new
things with them well yeah and i think
the thing is that the computers kind of
have killed the romance a little bit
from these fantastic openings that you
saw in the olden days you know where
they were sacrificing pieces here and
there and
everywhere so everyone's a little bit
kind of nervous about going into these
super sharp openings and instead they're
kind of like well actually let's take a
look at these
more solid openings shall we say they're
equally interesting
if you're inclined that way
and yeah it's just a game
and here we see ding
playing i didn't expect this move but it
is one of the main ideas i thought he
might try and challenge the center but
instead he chooses to
make a square for the light squared
bishop yep so black's light squared
bishop it didn't have anywhere to go
it's always the problem piece in these
queens pawn openings but black's like
square bishop can come out to a couple
of different squares now and
personally i always prefer white
slightly in these positions if you look
in the center of the board white has a
stronghold there with the pawns white
has two pawns and the e and d lines
black only has one it always feels like
black is the one fighting to equalize
and
yeah i think your rank is right often
players especially the top players now
they go back to the oldest openings or
openings which have fallen out of
fashion they discover new things there
and then they start playing it fashions
change everyone copies them then they
look back at what's forgotten again and
that's how fashion changes in chess it's
always at this point there's not much
new under the sun it's always
rediscovering older uh older variations
like the cambridge
springs variation
we did hear magnus in the video in the
break talk about novelties which must be
so nice when you get to play novelty so
are we seeing a lot of novelties are we
seeing less novelties now
with the with computers and everything
we're still seeing new moves new ideas
novelties but often they're less kind of
groundbreaking than they used to be um
they're
i mean still occasionally but they're
kind of best kind of novelties and
completely brand new uh brand new idea
that nobody's even thought of before and
you use it you win in style you smash
your opponent off the board nowadays
novelties they're kind of new
places to put your pieces small
maneuvering ideas that just confuse your
opponent essentially you don't
i mean it's very rare to win directly
from a novelty nowadays what is that
what is the description of a novelty
what is a novelty if you look it up in
any book it's i guess it's just a brand
new move that's never been played before
um
and the problem does it have to be a
good move
ideally
i don't think it should be a bad move
sometimes though it's maybe the third or
fourth choice according to the computer
but it's
kind of got practical value it tests
your opponent from a human point of view
it's harder to react to
um i remember i think my proudest
novelty was against levon aronian in
gibraltar a couple of years ago and
i mean it was just the computer's top
move but nobody had ever found it before
and i played it i i mean i studied it
deeper of course i used it and i won in
20 something moves but um
it's very rare it's like once in a every
few years that you get an idea
like that normally because people study
with computers they see the best moves
and they're not surprised and also the
the novelty has it has to happen like my
my former chess coach he has he showed
me this preparation this novelty that he
was going to play if he ever happened at
that in that exact situation but i don't
know if he still has yeah
he never played any games where so far
at least maybe yeah where he could do
that one move that he's been studying
and he wants to do because it's normally
not like in the like really really early
in the opening it can be a little bit
later uh-huh i once saved up a novelty
for six years i finally finally got a
chance to play it i remembered what the
move was i couldn't remember the
uh follow-up managed to win the game but
i think i spent 55 minutes on one move
like just after the novelty because i
was like what was it
what was it again i remember it was good
but i can't remember what it was and uh
okay meanwhile a couple of developments
but it's mostly just both kings castling
to safety it's very tense in the center
of the board and
first instincts here heidi now just
notice that the players played really
quickly in the beginning and then they
stopped both of them stopped to think
for for
a bit longer so maybe they're doing like
like you they're trying to remember
their way forward in this life yeah yeah
yeah i feel like this is perhaps a
critical moment actually you know
because uh pragnanda does have the
opportunity to kind of push in the
center or maybe he can kind of continue
with other things so definitely a good
moment to pause i think yeah often
that's a good tip for everyone at home
once you reach the end of your knowledge
once you reach a position that's either
new to you or at least not so familiar
then you should stop um just reassess
calculate a little bit come up with a
plan and you mentioned this move your
anchor pushing forward with the white
pawn has this been played before it has
been played for it's actually not the
most popular move it's just for the one
that
i liked the most because after all
taking a center with the pawns it's
always good in my opinion
and uh they're actually the most popular
move if we take one move back is
actually to trade off bishops
trading bishops first the black queen
will recapture and maybe now to push
forward in the center
yeah actually yes that's an option but
the most popular move again you know
we're talking about margin there's nine
games in database five games white is
actually played in a really
sophisticated ways offering a trade of
queens wow okay interesting so the
queen's now staring at each other if
black takes a step back maybe the black
queen's on a worse square but if black
does say yes and trade the queens then
okay white has some pressure along this
line
and maybe white will gain a bit more
space for example actually the black
bishop is lacking squares if the black
pawn pushes forward maybe now you kick
it to the edge of the board and the
black bishop here is not a very happy
bunny also i mean this black knight is
almost trapped as well um it has to take
a step back to some worse squares
uh so really interesting
in the current position will prague just
try and trade everything off head
towards the end game
and uh trade off the bishops then offer
that trade of queens as we mentioned or
is he going to be more ambitious maybe
keep all the pieces on the board attack
this knight i think i've seen this
position before or at least something's
very similar we'll see a trade of
knights white has a beautiful pawn
center but black does gain a bit of time
black's bishop normally moves to the
edge and when the rook kind of relocates
we do see okay he does go for this we do
see what we call a grunfeld type of pawn
structure because this pawn structure
always comes from the grunfeld opening
usually not this time and at some point
after maybe another trade we'll see
black challenge in the center of the
board either with this pawn or maybe
even with this pawn and white's position
looks nice and pretty at the moment but
black definitely has some ideas
yeah
it's quite interesting because i was
going to say if i had if i just walked
past this board and i didn't know the
evaluation i would prefer to be black in
the in the
uh the position that they were in before
that pawn move just because there are so
many
um
like you can't move the the knight and
and the bishop
in the h line is kind of kind of
pointing at
nothing
yeah
but after your uh after you look through
the move then yeah the white looks
better yeah i mean i think you're right
as well i mean black is so active if
black gets one more move and kind of
breaks out in the center and maybe
centralizes some of the black rooks
black is doing well but it's all about
timing and
big moment now for ding if he does trade
the knights as i just showed a moment
ago then white does establish this kind
of perfect pawn center
the problem is what else if you don't
trade these nights you don't really want
to go back
somehow it feels like you're not really
challenging white center so much
at some point white might even start
pushing forward gaining a bit of space
and gaining a bit of time as well so
this is the current position it's all
about what to do with this black knight
is under fire and it has to move either
you retreat or you trade off
i'm not sure what ding wants i mean end
game stats wise
both these players are pretty good at
end games but
pragnanda ever since he's been young
he's had a special flair
in
kind of simpler positions yeah
and while sting is taking well a
critical moment pause
well we do have a you know quiz of the
day where we're asking what is your
opening nightmare i love listening and
reading out your
answers i know but i mean at the same
time it's like i feel you i feel you
i've been there i've done that and uh
christopher grassley
says speaking of opening disasters
heidi
managed to get this opening trap in as
white in our club championships and uh
it's the famous uh
where you check mate in uh very few
moves yeah against the carrot card
it was actually quite uh quite uh funny
because i was at the good night the
weekend before i played this game and we
were looking at exactly what happened
here and then it happened just some days
later yeah
really and then you won yeah yeah yeah
and and this game also made it to the
newspaper because it's i think it's
checkmate and it was it's six moves or
six weeks yeah so um it's very easy to
show in the newspaper column yeah it's
actually caught many unsuspecting
victims
and uh
yeah no it has and you know remember
simon was talking about uh when he was
playing um an opponent yesterday he was
like nervously shaking it actually
happened
famously in a big danish tournament when
it was a grand master against someone
who was rated maybe 600 points below him
and the guy was shaking getting all
nervous like oh you know i'm going to
play my first super grand master and
then he goes and falls for this opening
trap in six moves maybe we can show on
the board you can talk us through it
um so you start with the king's pawn uh
ivanka's favorite opening the kara khan
say one of the white knights comes out
we see a trade of pawns in the center
black's night develops just to support
the other night and heidi show us your
brilliant checkmate the white queen
moves
and it's like the most natural move on
the board
there it is yeah maybe the viewers want
to see if they can see it yeah checkmate
in one move pause this uh yeah pause
this video just for a couple of seconds
if you want it's white playing checkmate
in one move kaya
well i i was gonna say tweet us your
fantastic hashtag chess jam
i need help
just check oh okay okay gotta get the
black king
we'll catch up with the game in a moment
you think we're using the night
yes
nice one and sorry if you've just
tweeted in but uh i think we should show
it on the board
yes it's so beautiful the white knight
actually jumps to a square that looks
that it like it can get captured but due
to a pin on this line the black pawn
cannot actually move and uh
yeah it's a bit of a smothered mate the
black king is trapped within and behind
its own pieces so six move track mate
wow yeah in a region we call it a
strangling mate it's like the the king
can't breathe yeah
oh how cool is it is it fun to win like
that or or do you feel a little bit
sorry for your opponent never
i am sorry for the brutal honesty
but it's always delightful to win by
checkmate yeah
very cool yeah you've got to be ruthless
in chess
especially when it's quite a pretty
checkmate it's an unexpected one like
that one
and uh meanwhile back in this game we
did see a trade of knights as we
indicated so white has established a
really nice pawn center
and it's time for black to start
chipping away at white's central points
you can't allow white to kind of control
the center this
uh too much longer
if white
controls the center maybe then we'll see
a build up of an attack against the
black king maybe the white pawns in the
middle will continue pushing up the
board ding now over the next few moves
it's really critical moments he needs to
push one of his own black pawns or at
least needs to trade some pieces in
order to challenge those two central
white pawns yeah and talking about
trades
i would probably just swap those light
square bishops off immediately
because one of the patterns that i'm i'm
kind of terrified of is if the white
pawn in the center that eric the e pawn
were to step one one square forward
and the light squared bishop were to
remain on that diagon also moved away
from
attack for example here yep and suddenly
this bishop is a monster piece you know
it's there is the anchorman or anchor
lady to any light square attack and uh
that is why i'm very relieved for pr for
ding that uh he actually swapped those
bishops off yeah one common checkmating
idea is to lift the queen up and along
this diagonal you kind of sneak into the
black king and you trap it so yep the
queen's sorry the bishops did indeed
come off the board um in this position
we saw ding just trade off the bishops
and now he moves his rook across and i
said it was kind of high time to start
pushing one of these two pawns forward
ding is keeping prague guessing he's
just saying okay i might throw um the
black sea pawn forward to trade off here
and open up a line for this black rook i
might throw the e pawn forward and trade
off here to open up a line for this
black rook but you can guess which one
i'm going to choose depending on what
you do
and now ivanka's idea of pushing the
pawn forward still a bit tempting but at
least now there won't be a checkmate
along this diagonal because white has
lost well he's had his light squared
bishop traded off and uh another piece
that wants to join rejoin the party
maybe this bishop um this bishop hidden
thinner it's just about what to do now
is white it looks it looks really
beautiful aesthetically for white all of
his pieces are great but what to do next
one argument could be maybe pushing this
pawn forward creating a nice kind of
trio here but this would also um just
leave a few squares undefended for
example if black now pushes in the
center if you continue to push with
white white hasn't uh sorry the black
knight has a nice outpost now coming
towards the queen
we're going to see a situation at some
point where um in the current position
white does push forward but black will
gain squares and it's just black kind of
curling up into a ball at some point one
of these pawn pushes will occur
it's just it's like mind games in a way
it's kind of ding saying okay you come
at me i'm ready and prag saying i want
to come at you but i'm not sure how
maybe it does involve pushing this pawn
that'll just be too tempting for me but
uh either way any pawn pushes require
commitment so advantage sting then
slightly
psychologically maybe but uh i think
objectively on the board i would prefer
to be white just because the pawns look
so nice in the middle
it's just what to do with them yeah
that's the big question yeah i was going
to ask you about um ding's strategy
because you know we can't forget that
pragananda's so young and one of the
traditional stereotypes is when you're
playing someone who's young
well you know they get a bit over
ambitious they get over eager impatient
and by adopting this kind of solid as a
rock formation
and waiting for pragnanda to do
something is he kind of tempting him to
making a commitment and then
maybe the play will become easier for
ding yeah quite possibly i mean my kind
of go-to strategy in rapid and
especially blitz chess is actually to do
nothing just make sure everything's
protected curl up in a ball and my
opponents always burn time on the clock
because planning is actually the hardest
thing
i mean the top level players they
calculate so quickly
but when you kind of formulate a plan
that kind of requires four or five moves
you have to consider the opponent's
ideas that's when they really do burn uh
those valuable seconds and that's what i
mean pregnant is doing now he spent
three minutes on this one move he has
lots of
good moves lots of decent moves lots of
interesting plans but just choosing
among the different plans
that's the hardest thing in chess
there are no attacks there are no
variations to calculate really there's
no threats
you just have to choose one plan and
stick with it
but yeah he's dropping down a bit on the
clock and i think that's dean's tactic
to answer your question ivanka
ding he's
just happy i think to see prague
thinking
yeah
and the moment the most famous example
i've heard of the do nothing approach
was actually from peter lecko i think
when he played vladimir kramnik right in
their world championship match 2004.
2004 yeah he did like lecco peter lecker
did nothing and like and didn't even i
think sometimes didn't even try to win
you know just there was like nothing
coming from him and uh this just drove
vladimir kramnik crazy
yeah because it is annoying yeah and uh
peter lecko almost won it
yeah wow he was one game away kramnik
had to win on demand in the last game
just to maintain the title
uh so yeah peter leko i mean that's what
i love to do just frustrate the opponent
just no matter what it is whether it's
doing nothing whether it's being super
aggressive if you find out what your
opponent hates
that's half the battle um you do it to
them they get
i don't know they get angry and then
yeah and you mentioned like if you find
out how they ha well if you find out
what they hate
how do you do this how do you kind of
like get these signs from their games or
is it perhaps having to not getting to
know the players personally i mean i i
know a lot of the top players but i try
and do this myself i try and research as
much as possible so i play through
hundreds of my opponents games just to
get a
handle on their style if they lose a lot
of games to see
you know what the kind of um
you know what how they lose the game
every single time what those losses have
in common and if they always lose in a
rook end game then i'll try and steal
the game towards a rookie game if they
always lose in a certain pawn structure
i'll try and get that pawn structure if
they're always losing a certain opening
i'll try and trick them into that
opening
and i think it's the same for the top
players of course it's small margins but
i think at all levels
that's so clever this is such a great
piece of advice yeah i've never ever
thought about doing this most of us just
check the openings and say i'll react to
that
but uh i always play through their most
recent 50 100 games and even if it's
quite quick play through you always get
a sense for the patterns that emerge and
i think even at the lower levels you
might not be able to research your
opponent's games maybe the opponent's
games aren't online or on the databases
but you can find out you can talk to
their friends their club mates what are
their weaknesses you know gotta do a
little bit of a spy do a bit of recon
yeah very clever now after thinking for
over four minutes
eventually it did make a move uh was it
the h pawn move it was uh i mean
prague's actually done this in all games
so far today white's pawn just stepping
one square up giving the white king some
breathing space but
that's not the type of move you want to
cost here you want to cost four minutes
and meanwhile ding has slightly improved
black's pawn stepping forward black's
queen now
kind of eyeing up the white rook at the
bottom of the board
it feels like prague is just indecisive
uh what to do next
and uh yeah first instinct it just feels
like he's
he's kind of tensed up he's a bit frozen
he wants to be in a position where the
moves just flow naturally
like in the last game he was calculating
he was improving his pieces on every
turn i'm not sure he's
so comfortable right now i find it so
hard to play when i can't find a plan
when i'm looking for a plan
it's it's the worst yeah that's
definitely the hardest thing in chess
and i think that's one thing that people
forget to train on
just planning just that's why you should
always kind of
read through books read through
magazines especially when the players
talk about their own thoughts just put
the position on the board and see oh how
would i approach this position what do i
think first and then if you can read the
players the top players their own
thoughts
and kind of compare it to your own
conclusions that's
a good way to train and i guess the
saying goes uh a bad plan is better than
no plan but i heard it's a controversial
thing that is very controversial
it's one where you probably need ty to
do the statistics
where someone had no plan yeah uh yeah
and uh right the bishop actually
retreats all the way to its home square
um presumably just getting ready for any
potential
uh right side attack yeah he's really
mastering the art of doing nothing ding
he's kind of just put his bishop back on
a safe square just asking prague what
are you doing
i have a bad feeling for pranks time
management i mean this is the kind of
thing i do all the time i'm always in
time trouble but if i ask myself
afterwards what was i thinking about
often it was just frustration
often it was it was like heidi said just
looking for a plan and
kind of beating yourself up it's like i
can't find anything why can't i find
anything and then you kind of stop
calculating
it starts going downhill from there
if you look at the white rooks as well
they're nicely kind of doubled up but
the white rooks are staring at their own
pawn
i don't really see how prague has
improved his position over the last five
moves
and four minutes now it's still quite
early in the game yeah he needs to speed
up right he needs to make a move prague
he looks ready to do it now looking for
that plan
what will the move be the time
management is so difficult as well yeah
is that something you struggle with uh
heidi yeah i i i spent so much time
trying to find the plan try and uh well
i should just swap all the pieces and
then go into the end game because then
it's so much easier for me to find the
plan the fewer pieces on the board the
easier it is
talking about plans uh well pragnanda
has revealed his intentions and i have
to admit i thought it but again i talked
myself out of this time thing i was like
no you mean don't go that you don't need
to push pawns in front of your king and
what made me a bit hesitant was that
white doesn't have too many minor pieces
and that light square bishop missing
yeah and uh i could feel actually you
were going to suggest it a bit earlier
i just had a feeling i nearly showed up
on the board earlier but i thought it's
never going to happen why would we show
it but it has happened and the whole
idea and
we should explain as well black has
something that we call a hook that means
this pawn has moved one square forward
if this pawn was just back on its
starting square then it would be much
harder to attack black structure would
be completely intact but because this
pawn has moved one square forward white
can use it as a hook to kind of wrench
open the position and for example if
black just plays slowly now the white
pawn will push forward trying to open up
lines trying to capture this black pawn
if we see a capture for example the
white knight might start jumping into a
nice attacking position at some point we
might see um again white king slide
across white's rook now uh kind of slide
onto this open line towards the black
king stuff is starting to happen around
the black king the downside and the
reason we were so surprised uh behind
this pawn push is firstly it's a bit
slow uh the plans there we talked about
require three four moves to push this
pawn forward but also it does open up
the white king as well so it's pros and
cons normally if the center is closed
you can afford
liberties and luxuries like pushing
pawns near your king but if the center
is open then it will backfire and that's
why ding pushed his pawn forward trying
to open up the center of the board
trying to open up lines for the black
rook and after prague says no i'm going
to close it down again
ding is continuing to push forward and
it's all about timing here
prague might well live to regret the
fact he's pushed this pawn forward and
exposed his king slightly it's a bit
loose now and the white queen no matter
where she goes
i think ding's idea is to bring the
black knight into a lovely outpost
in the middle of the board
the bar is going up for ding 1.1 pawn
advantage is what the computers are
saying and what's this simply thing
ready to take advantage of uh prague
finally deciding on a plan yeah i think
prague chose a plan maybe he was
thinking oh bad plans
but
um
yeah i mean it's it's hard to criticize
price kind of moves because it's
ambitious i like the idea behind it
going on the attack against the black
king but it's just too slow and look at
how fast ding has mobilized his pawns
it's like a it's like a mirror image of
the first game throwing pawns down
against the white uh queen side i was
gonna call it brutal beth you know it's
going to be almost a repeat actually if
that pawn is allowed to start marching
even further actually yeah it's
literally a carbon copy of the of the
first game today where ding one just
throwing pawns down where prague wasn't
ready
i don't really see what to do now
i mean
no matter what you do with whites it
just feels like black's pieces are
coming to life
wow what a strange date the black
seems to be the pieces to have today
yeah i think that's quite interesting
and i'm wondering if it's because you
know when you play with the white pieces
you're expected to have a little
advantage or you should try to win when
you're playing with the white pieces and
maybe maybe the players are pushing too
much or
not finding the plan properly and it's
actually a good thing to be black yeah
yeah it's easier to kind of just sit and
do nothing and counter-attack as black
and
i definitely feel prague we talked about
that pawn push going on the attack
that's because he's white he thinks oh
i've got white i need to win i need to
attack but then sometimes you just you
lose objectivity and uh okay we did see
a quick trade of pawns white's knight
jumping into the center attacking a
black rook but
that look uh that black rook happy to
slide across and support beth the people
and ivanka
i'm loving this um i
it's it feels a little bit cruel though
to pragnanda that it's the same pawn
that's uh that bothered him on game one
is now uh
fully there in pester mode it's ready
game three
um it's really rare that that happens
actually super rare yeah
yeah you very rarely see one player
falls at the same uh defeat twice in a
way and the reason we say that this ball
is so dangerous is because you simply
can't take it if you take this pawn
right now then the black bishop comes
along and whoops that's a skewer the
white queen has to move the white rook
will drop behind it on this diagonal so
okay prague is trying to bail out and
trying to escape from this really
difficult situation by offering a queen
trade
i'm not sure i'm not sure ding's going
to accept even if he does i think it's
quite good for black but at the very
least you can push your pawn forward two
squares away from promotion now and
you can block the queen trade along this
diagonal in the process
you could also make an argument for just
trading queens the very simple approach
and then for example bring the black
knight into this nice outpost maybe now
if you're feeling greedy you could grab
a pawn
i don't think
you can push your pawn forward here i
think the one trap that prague has set
is that if the black pawn does march
forward then after a trade we can see
the white knight eliminate this pawn
that's the b pawn now because after the
white knight is captured whoops loose
pieces drop off and this knight is
hanging and here we would see just
everything getting traded queens knights
pawns and likely a draw so i think
that's what prague's idea is but ding to
trade or not to trade
what do you do here heidi ivanka well i
just
took a look at the computer and the
computer says both of those moves
winning both winning wow and he does
trade and he does grab a pawn so no more
beth the b pawn we have two
charlies what's the seafood charlie
charlie is a good one double charlie and
uh black is a pawn up temporarily white
goes after one of the weak pawns uh the
double pawns at least and now black
leaping in i'm not such a fan of what
ding has just done i must say um he's
kind of banking on the fact that these
pawns or at least one of them will stay
alive but
um if one of them falls maybe the other
one will as well so
okay he's counter-attacking against this
central pawn
okay
developments a capture and another
capture black is just one pawn up for
free it's one side of traffic yeah
definitely and uh i was just gonna say
that the rook probably was forced to cap
to attack the knight
because
black could even think about attacking
the bishop with the pawn yeah at some
point black's pawn can come forward
attack this bishop which is offside on
the edge of the board first now you can
just move your knight any safe square i
think
this one this one
and uh yeah this eventually this one
extra pawn should tell still some hard
work to get it through to start pushing
it
but uh yeah pawn is a pawn yeah i've
been really impressed by
ding's handling of the black side of
these openings you know first of all his
first game was a fantastic model game
and this one is also a
great example of just outwitting your
opponent
from something where visually it looks
like it looked quite good for white
and he did nothing and then
he made small improvements here and then
suddenly
he's winning
and some people actually my teammates
tell me this is how i play with kara
khan having like a position which they
look at and they go that's disgusting
and then like and then when they come
back and move 40 they go
i don't know but she's upper pawn
and now she's grinding it out
how did that happen that's exactly
ding's strategy in this game pretty much
i know i'm going to go back and study
this opening a bit more because
i i don't really know what white went
wrong like where he went wrong what he
could have done instead i mean it's a
bit like the first game prague didn't
really blunder he was just had a big
disadvantage a few minutes later no
it's hard to explain sometimes it is a
bit difficult as well and i do know that
this particular opening is very very
trendy and it was actually recommended
by sam shankland in his samislav
chesaboard course and there's actually
for those fans of the slav there's
actually a new chessboard course on the
slab semi slot being released
uh by seth thurman
okay so
more great stuff coming from
everyone at the team at chesmar
absolutely
all right well this one dingley ren
maybe is he heading for another win with
the black pieces and putting prague in
another
uh comeback situation in game four still
one game to play in the first match
today after this game
the knight moves yeah the knight steps
back i guess the idea is to just go over
and blockade black's extra pawn black's
sea pawn is the dangerous one so maybe
the white knight wants to go and park
itself in front of that pawn but he can
tell him prague's body language is
suddenly
less optimistic there's no shaking
there's no energy
that we've seen from him
maybe because he's late at night he's
been doing an exam today but
also because of the position on the
board it's one-sided black is the only
one who can win barring a miracle here
white is fighting for his life fighting
for the draw yeah
and okay bishop now attacks the rook and
when you find yourself in these types of
positions do you what do you tell
yourself to motivate yourself
i mean because i know a lot of chess
players they're a bit pessimistic and
they hate being in these horrible
positions and they just go off it's
disgusting why why am i here they do you
do society they question their life
existence even the strong player they're
super strong players are doing this and
they resign and they're just like okay
enough move on to the next
i often have to play even though i know
i'm going to lose i have to play for a
bit longer because i'm so upset on the
inside that i have to like calm down
before before i give up but i also think
uh because i mean my level is obviously
a lot lower than these guys that you can
learn a lot even though you play a bad
position maybe you can you can learn how
to uh try to defend as good as possible
um so i often also continue playing just
to play more chess even though it looks
horrible
yeah that's actually good that's really
good advice actually to kind of adapt to
the learning
mentality yeah and i i mean ever since i
read this book by jonathan rousen the
seven deadly chess sins i call it the
goalkeeper's glory it's um basically a
goalkeeper in football soccer
i mean you don't you never score goals
you never actually win anything in
especially for example in a penalty
shootout nobody expects you to save it
but if you do like in a chess game in a
hopeless position if you do save it you
feel on top of the world you're the hero
you're not going to win the game
necessarily but a draw feels like a
victory so i just kind of think of
myself in a losing position like a
goalie i'm like okay
not much chance but i'll try and save it
if i can i'll try and stop my opponent
from scoring oh i can imagine you david
burning gold
if i can do it
and i especially think in in like if
you're a beginner you have to play and
no matter what if you're playing against
other beginners because i've seen so
many games that looked like they were
100 percent one
for for one side and then the other one
wins
yeah
you always learn something along the way
anyway um in terms of defense or how to
finish things off
uh meanwhile prague he didn't look happy
there a minute ago just rubbing his eyes
but he has at least blockaded black's
extra pawn black sea pawn for now can't
move
problem is this white knight's not on a
stable square this white knight can get
kicked away by black's rook or by
black's bishop
i would be very tempted to move the
black bishop now to hit this knight oh
he does not look happy pregnant on the
bar
all the way up for dingli ren is he
going to win another game here
it's certainly looking good for ding
and
well the move that david recommend is on
the board and well prank is in full
goalkeeper mode you know knight was
attacked had to be defended
yeah and uh here question for ding how
to progress how to kind of you've got
the one point advantage how to keep that
momentum going how to really kind of try
and kick pregnant while he's down
especially while he's got one minute on
the clock and a couple of options here i
mean first thing that comes to my mind
is just keep things simple get rid of
the blockade of your porn knights of the
best blockaders so eliminate it and why
not just get greedy grab this pawn two
pawns up
it still takes a lot to win this
actually
these pawns they don't run that quickly
surprisingly they will be stopped by the
white rooks but two pawn advantage no
risk at all
should be winning i think long term
another idea would be to maybe sideline
this bishop first i'm slightly concerned
about this bishop taking the black
knight and wrecking the black pawn
structure it's a fair trade but maybe
you don't want to compromise your pawn
structure you could push this pawn
forward
okay he doesn't want to allow that
bishop for nitrate uh instead of pushing
a pawn he goes back with the black
knight hitting this rook and maybe
there's a root for this knight into the
position for example if it moves uh if
the white rook moves maybe the black
knight is jumping in this way towards
the white rook
interesting uh interesting idea there
from ding i mean he's got a pawn he's
got an extra pawn
he's hit making threats
he's the one in control three extra
minutes on the clock as well it's just
hard it's hard to imagine saving this in
any
world at the moment
less than 30 seconds now for prague
okay and uh he retreats his rook one
square i like this one at least it
stopped the black knight going to the
other square i mentioned because the
white rook was attacking black's sea
pawn so black's knight now on the
defensive
oh what's that white bishop doing you
mentioned it heidi like what was it 20
moves ago that white bishop it's just
been sidelined actually on the side of
the board
pushing
forward that pawn's going nowhere but at
least it's not
targeted by the black rook
look at prague it seems like he's just
finished with this game planning the
next one
or does he look tired i don't know i
think he looks tired i think it was this
exam
um
yeah to get up
at it was his exam was at 8 45 yeah so
when he finished the final at the
semi-final yesterday at 2 30 in the
morning in india and then he had to be
at school by 8 30 to do his exam
and then turning up here at uh was it 9
30 in india i think it's what is it past
midnight now
it's not easy
um yeah i mean he's a superhuman effort
to even get this far to win the last
game but this one is falling apart dingo
still has to win it he still has to put
that ball in the back of the net
how to do that i mean the black rook now
on the second low and the second line on
b2 could just take a step back kick away
this white knight
as soon as that black pawn starts
motoring it should be
game over
hmm
it's a little bit of a position where
the pieces are all over the board it's
not like they're centralized somewhere
where is sort of the main area for ding
to get that win i think it's all about
that black sea pawn actually if you look
at if you forget the white pieces for a
moment if you only look at black's army
they've all gravitated to the b and the
c files so that's where black's kind of
focuses he doesn't need to worry about
the black king queens are off there
won't be any attacks so black's focus is
now on the b and c files but especially
the black seaborne that is the potential
winner that's his extra pawn white's
army uh you mentioned that kai white is
the one that's actually a bit scattered
there's less coordination and harmony
especially that white bishop on the edge
of the board white's rook in the center
looks nice and pretty but not really
doing much and there we go
the blockade is getting kicked away and
the white knight now on the edge
eyeing up the black bishop but the black
bishop can just move
maybe you don't even need to move it
yeah i thought she can also be supported
as well by pawn
so
the choice is in ding's hands yeah i'm
starting to understand why pregnant has
given up hope it just looks
i mean completely lost unfortunately
the black bishop attacking white's rook
the white rook will step up one square
maybe the black pawns coming now
maybe the black bishop can move okay
there we go the pawn does advance
white's rook in front of it is
completely uh cut out of the game
white's rook now and the white knight in
the corner
just immobilized
well 30 seconds for prague he's gonna
keep fighting right it's not like he's
gonna give up right now i think until
that black pawn continues to break
through or until something else drops
yeah you're only one pawn down for now
so keep fighting the computer does say
plus five nearly so that means that it's
almost hopeless but in human terms
nine seconds for brag it's not much time
it's always very uh
nerve-wracking yeah the players let the
seconds tick down
okay so the rook moves across you know
potentially setting up a trap as the two
rooks eye each other out there's
oh unfortunately i think this might be
the killer blacks rook is just removing
the blockader off his seat pawn white's
rook now on the c2 square stuck if you
trade off rooks black is just going to
create beth the b-pawn again and gonna
queen that pawn again
and uh there we go we have a result ding
takes it wow it's over again with the
black pieces ding wins this game to
again take the lead in the match in the
fight